about that uh
directed to chris witte really about how
are the hospitals coping is there a
point that they will be overwhelmed or
not what does he think the outlook is in
the coming weeks around hospitals but as
for the prime minister uh he was quite
clear uh yesterday when he gave an
interview uh following uh the christmas
period that uh while it's gonna get
tough for the next few weeks he wants to
stick to plan b i expect that will be
the message again today and when i talk
to people inside government about what
the focus is they keep stressing
the need for boosters and rolling out
the booster program and getting more
people vaccinated
and more people tested and i think
that's going to be uh something that he
will certainly focus on in this press
conference as i understand it he might
talk about increasing daily testing for
those working in critical industries so
asking people in critical industries to
do more lateral flow tests so that they
pick up whether they have omicron early
before they infect other members of
staff so will he talk about uh requiring
more testing in critical industries and
infrastructure that we all rely on i'm
thinking about food distribution maybe
uh airlines and and so on and so forth
and then on the issue of boosters well
after a very successful roller in the
run-up to christmas uh there has been a
drop-off in people uh taking that boost
to that third dose of the vaccine and it
might be the case i'm just trying to
find my notes on where we've got to the
booster number peaked on december the
21st with nearly 1 million doses 968 000
on sunday which was the latest data
released just a hundred and six thousand
uh boosters and as someone in government
uh said to me earlier we were talking
about it it's always uh the last stages
that it gets really difficult to get
people out and get them boosted once the
majority or a big
chunk of people have been boosted then a
number the last people
are often reluctant to go so will the
prime minister begin to press that again
there is some talk about whether or not
they might change uh the rules and
regulations so that covered passports
aren't just those two doses you all
might have had uh in the summer and into
the winter but might also require a
boost or a third dose of vaccine for
your covered passport to be valid will
the prime minister uh talk about that
today so there's lots of things to talk
about i think what's clear
from what government ministers have said
and what the prime minister's already
said this week that when it comes to
plan b he's sticking with the current
restrictions with a focus instead on
ramping up testing and booster booster
doses right beth it's uh mark austin
here now uh in the studio coming up to
uh five o'clock the newshour we're
gathering uh we gather that he'll be
with us in about a minute or so
um but i mean this is more broadly beth
a beleaguered prime minister behind in
the polls and he'll be hoping that a new
year means a you know a new page in his
uh premiership
well that's exactly it too mark that
this is a prime minister that had a
torrid time to the end of last year
with those reports over christmas
parties uh in downing street sue gray uh
one of a permanent secretary of very
senior civil servant now leading that
investigation has been uh having formal
meetings and interviews with members of
his team okay we're going to stop
boris johnson is about to speak
fastest growth in kobe cases that we've
ever known
previous waves of the pandemic didn't
have a single day with more than a
hundred thousand new cases reported
one day last week we had 200 000 people
test positive and the latest figure
today is another 218 000 though with uh
that includes some delayed reports
so anyone who thinks our battle with
covid is over i'm afraid is profoundly
wrong
this
is a moment for the utmost caution but
our position today differs from previous
waves in two crucial respects first
we now know that omicron is milder than
previous variants so while hospital
admissions are rising quickly with over
fifteen thousand covered patients now in
hospital in england alone this is not
yet thankfully translating into the same
numbers needing intensive care that we
saw in previous waves second
thanks to the fantastic national effort
to get britain boosted we now have a
substantial level of protection higher
than any of our european neighbors with
over 34 million boosters administered
including in england reaching more than
90 of the over 70s and 86 percent of the
over 50s
and so together with the plan b measures
that we introduced before christmas
we have a chance
to ride out this omicron wave without
shutting down our country once again
we can keep our schools and our
businesses open and we can find a way to
live with this virus
but the weeks ahead are going to be
challenging
both here in the uk and across the world
there is no escaping the fact that some
services will be disrupted by staff
absences
but we've been working through christmas
to prepare for this wherever possible
and if we all play our part in
containing the spread of this virus the
disruptions we face
can be far less severe than a national
lockdown with all the devastation that
would bring for the livelihoods and the
life chances of our children
so the government is acting to protect
critical national services to keep
supply chains open and fortify our nhs
to withstand the pressures ahead
we've identified a hundred thousand
critical workers
in areas from food processing to
transport to our border force
and from the 10th of january we'll be
rolling out lateral flow testing for all
these workers available on every working
day
we'll be sending testing kits directly
to these organizations and liaising with
them on the logistics
we've asked qualified teachers who have
left the profession to come back and
help fill temporary absences and i want
to thank them and all teachers parents
and pupils for taking the precaution to
test yourselves and to wear a mask in
the classroom enabling vital face to
face education to continue
we're increasing nhs capacity by
building on-site nightingale hospitals
as well as creating 2500 virtual beds
where people can be safely treated at
home
we've bought more antivirals per person
than anywhere else in europe those are
the tablets which reduce your chances of
going to hospital once you've caught
covet
we're mobilizing our volunteers the
emerging territorial army of the nhs and
we're working to identify those nhs
trusts which are most likely to need
actual military support so that this can
be prepared now
as our nhs moves to a war footing i will
be recommending to cabinet tomorrow that
we continue with plan b
because the public have responded and
changed their behavior changed your
behavior buying valuable time to get
boosters in arms and help the nhs to
cope with the omicron wave
so please carry on observing those
measures for now work from home if you
can
wear face coverings on public transport
and in indoor places and take a test
before you go to a high risk venue or
meet those who are elderly or vulnerable
and of course follow the relevant rules
if you live in scotland or wales or
northern ireland
above all if you haven't already done so
please please get that booster
since i launched the get boosted now
campaign on the 12th of december we've
delivered 10 million extra boosters
across the uk
we've doubled the rate of vaccination
from 450 000 doses a day to a peak of
more than nine hundred thousand
we matched the nhs's previous record day
and then beat it again and again and we
met our target of offering a booster to
every eligible adult a whole month early
the freedoms were able to maintain in
the teeth of this omicron wave have been
made possible by the number of people
getting boosted and i want to thank
again everyone who assisted in this
extraordinary national effort over
christmas our gps and their teams
pharmacists everybody in our fantastic
nhs the thousands of volunteers the
ingenious initiatives of local
communities like the one in redbridge
town hall which vaccinated 1700 people
on christmas day and every one of you
who has come forward
and done your bit by getting jabbed but
there are still almost nine million
people eligible who haven't had their
boost and it's absolutely heartbreaking
as many as 90 percent of those in
intensive care with kovid have not had
their booster and over 60 percent of
those in intensive care have not had
with kovid have not had any vaccination
at all
people are dying needlessly because they
haven't had their jabs and they haven't
had that booster and there are two
million booster slots available this
week alone
it's already the case that to travel to
some countries you need a booster to be
considered fully vaccinated
and it's likely that within weeks this
will increasingly become the norm
so
if you haven't done it already get
yourself boosted this month
exactly a year after the uk administered
the first astrazeneca vaccine a british
invention that has enabled 2.5 billion
jabs around the world the best way to
contain this virus help our nhs and keep
our country open is to get boosted so
please get boosted now thank you and
chris owed you for the slides thank you
prime minister first side please
uh this is a familiar slide the number
of people testing positive for cobit 19
in the uk
and i think everybody knows there's been
a very substantial increase over the
last few weeks
next slide
please i thought however it was probably
sensible because uh there have been
significant changes in the way testing
is done uh
better to actually just look
particularly at the office for national
statistics ons data
uh which is uh in the public domain and
there will be uh updates on this soon
and as you can see this is uh these dots
represent how many people had covert at
various points in time going back to may
2020 using the same methodology
and the extraordinary increase on the
far right
where we've now got to the situation uh
where in the last week they have
reported uh 1 in 25 people in england
had covered more in some areas
around 2 million people in all and the
expectation is those numbers will in
fact go up
next slide please
the as several people uh have commented
in one of the good things that we've
learned since the last time we did a
press conference on this is data
both from south africa but also now all
around the world including
the uk
demonstrating that there are lower rates
of hospitalization
but lower does not mean there are not
hospitalizations there are significant
numbers and just to give uh some kind of
feel for this
uh at the moment there are just over 15
000 people
in hospital in england the data here of
the uk and a slightly later in time if
we went back to mid-december when we
when we were still with the delta wave
the number in hospital was between six
thousand and six thousand five hundred
so a very substantial increase people
are not admitted to hospital in the nhs
in winter unless they have a clear need
for hospitalization
and then to compare it to the previous
waves uh the wave that we had uh in uh
in in the early part of 2020
had 18
974 people at the absolute peak so
we are relatively close to that initial
peak the january peak last year was
higher
next slide please
if we look around the country uh we can
see uh obviously quite a variety of
different patterns london has been in
advance of the rest of england
and indeed other parts of the united
kingdom
the numbers however are still going up
there may be some slowing but they are
still going up
and i think the thing which i'd like
just to add in terms of the local
epidemiology in london is that it does
look as if the numbers in younger adults
are leveling off or falling although we
need to be quite careful because this is
before new year effects have actually
taken taken effect
but
rates in older people look as if they
are still going up and these are the
people who are much more likely to be
hospitalized and the thing which is
likely to reduce that to go back to the
prime minister's point is the fact that
people have got boosted but anybody who
has not been boosted as eligible really
should do so i think the idea that this
is a miles disease as opposed to less
likely to be hospitalized i think it's
easily demonstrated to be incorrect
based on these data
next slide please
there's quite a bit of commentary and i
just wanted to put some numbers on this
about whether people have are primarily
in hospital because of kovid or because
they have it incidentally they have
another medical problem but they have
covert on top there are of course people
with both that's been true all the way
through the pandemic
the majority of people who admitted uh
and have coveted uh i will have actually
have covered as their primary reason for
admission but obviously there are people
who that is also a significant minority
where that is not the case they're in
blue
and the orange data are for people
who've got a primary diagnosis of covid
next slide please
one thing which we have seen and which
is obviously
uh extremely good news compared to where
we were with previous waves is that the
mortality rate does not appear to have
risen
the numbers have been artificially low
over the last two or three days because
it's a long weekend and will be
artificially high tomorrow but we are
not seeing the surge in mortality that
we saw in in previous waves but there
will be people particularly people who
are vulnerable for other reasons because
of age or medical conditions who will
sadly die of this
next slide please
turning to the booster and the
vaccination campaign i think there are
really um two uh very uh important uh
positives to highlight the first of
which is the extraordinary speed with
which uh colleagues in the nhs and
volunteers have been able to provide and
people have come forward for boosters
and the very rapid increase we've had
and additionally and this is extremely
important
people who have previously had no
vaccines have come forward for their
first vaccine and people who'd
previously had a first vaccine have come
forward for their second and this each
one of these will help provide
additional protection but we now um have
uh confidence that the boosted the
booster provides around 88
overall protection against being
hospitalized
and it's likely to be even greater than
that for severe disease and mortality
next slide please
and finally just a slide i've shown
before because i just want to emphasize
this that at every age band
the uh that being vaccinated whether
it's a previous variance and it is
likely to be true for this
variant
every age band people are significantly
protected by vaccination
and it is really critical whatever age
people are that they do get vaccinate
for that we are confident this will also
lead to a reduction in people having uh
a booster lead to reduction in people
actually having kobit and therefore a
reduction in people's likelihood of
passing on kobed but the data are still
being developed so we don't have the
exact numbers but in terms of reducing
hospitalizations we are now confident
that boosting provides very significant
protection
and that the
one or two vaccines provide some level
of protection thank you very much indeed
thank you chris uh patrick
okay well let's let's go to uh questions
from
the uh the public and
we've got a question from david in kent
given the government has said it will be
guided by the data uh what level of
daily infections hospitalizations or
deaths will the government implement
tougher covered restrictions well thank
you dave i think that's the uh the
the key question that many people have
been uh thinking about throughout the uh
the the omicron uh pandemic and you you
have to think about omicron as a as a
as a disease an infection really uh
on it on its own as soon as we saw it
emerge uh we we knew that uh it was
likely to present a problem and if you
recall we we put in measures on i think
december the 8th we introduced plan b
and
i just want to say that i'm
incredibly grateful to
uh the nhs to everybody who's working so
hard in our hospitalization in our
hospitals uh now to uh to deal with uh
the pandemic but i do think that the the
balance of measures uh that we have is
the right one and uh the right one for
for omicron uh we'll continue to to
monitor it clearly but what we're saying
is that you've got to stick with with
plan b you've got to follow the the
guidance you've got to make sure you
wear a mask in uh confined spaces on
public uh transport you've got to make
sure you you get a test uh before you go
to a venue we're going to meet people
that you don't normally meet you've got
to make sure
that
you
for instance
do not uh
take unnecessary risk particularly with
uh with elderly people and above all uh
we've got to make sure that you get a a
vaccination and that is the
the
the most important thing uh
we wanted to have a mixture of plan b
uh and
a a greatly accelerated booster program
and i just want to say david that
it is
always difficult to balance these things
there is no
easy answer to
a
a problem like omicron there's no easy
lockdown there's no easy restriction on
people's lives or or livelihoods
and uh
the best thing i think we can do now is
to continue to follow the guidance uh
protect our nhs in the way that uh that
we are
increase the the support that we're
giving uh to the nhs and and as you know
you've heard from what i said earlier on
we're increasing the
uh the numbers of uh
of staff where we've got i think we've
got a record number of people working in
the nhs uh now than at any time in the
past five thousand more uh doctors ten
thousand
more nurses uh you'll have heard what
i've said about all the the volunteers
but the best way to to help the nhs
is for everybody uh to
follow the guidance follow plan b
and above all get boosted and i just
want to return to that
that
earlier
tragic reflection that so many people
going into
uh the nhs so many people who are being
hospitalized sadly
david have not been vaccinated as i said
about 61 percent of those uh in in icu
have not been vaccinated uh
at all and uh perhaps
90 percent uh have not been boosted so
the single best thing we can all do to
protect the nhs is to is to get boosted
and and to get vaccinated but
we will continue to uh to watch uh what
happens very closely but we think that
this is the right
the right approach to take it's a
balanced approach it has to balance a
lot of considerations it has to balance
the
uh
the effect on people's lives and
livelihoods of lockdowns which are
painful uh which take away people's uh
life chances
which do a great deal of
of social uh damage damage to people's
mental health as well as damage uh
damage to the economy so it's a
difficult balance to strike but that is
that is where we are anyway chris
anything to answer on
thank you uh let's go to
amanda from cheshire
amanda says i had covered at the
beginning of november and was told by
tests and trace not to take a lateral
flow test for 91 days as a result may
not be accurate
so how is it now reliable to use the
results of these tests on days six and
seven
to reduce the isolation period
does the 91 day period for not using
natural flow tests no longer apply
uh
chris i'm going to defer to you on this
one thank you prime minister um the the
answer is that the the key thing which
the lateral flow is really good at um is
it
it's the fact that it is a pretty good
guide very good guide actually to
whether someone is at that moment
infectious
and so the reason that we feel it is a
useful tool to allow on day six and day
seven uh if someone is isolated because
they know they've got covered to day
five and then they have a negative test
on day six and a negative test on day
seven
we have confidence they're much less
likely
to be in any way infectious to other
people if they then leave isolation
than if um they had not done those tests
so that's the reason why adding those
tests on allowed ministers to decide to
move from 10 days isolation uh down to
seven but the last two you do the
lateral test because they're very
predictive of how infectious someone is
obviously if they're still positive then
they do need to stay in isolation till
it goes negative
the the pcr tests which are the other
way of testing they can remain uh
positive for a long time after someone
has had an infection including beyond
the point where they are
infectious so the reason that we find
the pcr is extremely good because
they're very sensitive and they're
extremely good because they tell you
which type of variant of covid has got
many advantages but the lateral flows
are really good at helping to determine
whether someone is infectious at that
point to other people
thank you let's go to hugh pym now from
bbc news
thank you prime minister
would you say it's now unlikely or
highly unlikely that further
restrictions will be introduced in
england
and a question for sir patrick and sir
chris how worried are you about what
might yet happen and what do you think
might be a threshold requiring further
action
well
hugh thank you very much i i
just want to go back to what i was
saying to to david earlier on we'll we
will monitor everything very closely we
clearly can't uh rule anything out but
our what we're trying to do is take a a
balanced approach uh where we we rely on
people to to implement plan b
carefully to to think about and to to
behave carefully with other people and
the people are doing that you can tell
that people have really uh responded to
this and and and they're doing their
absolute best in spite of the extreme uh
transmissibility of omicron uh what
we're also doing is is massively
accelerating the booster rollout and
it's it's it's gone incredibly fast
i think that
at the moment
uh it it depends and uh
to be absolutely uh frank with you i
think it depends on the uh
the the whether the
virus will
behave in the way that perhaps it's
behaved in uh in south africa whether it
peaks how quickly uh it blows through
but if you are if you ask me to
to guess i would say we have a as i said
earlier on i said i would say we have a
good chance of getting through uh the
omicron wave uh without the need for uh
for further restrictions and without the
need certainly for a lockdown i think
that then the reason we're in that
position unlike many other countries uh
in the world certainly unlike many other
countries in in europe is that we just
have such a high level now of of booster
protection but that is no reason for
everybody not to get more
so
in terms of the um
what do we think going forward well we
know two things
well and that is this is very
transmissible and we have
extraordinarily high levels of infection
at the moment as indeed to many other
countries
so large numbers of people have the
disease we also know that this is not as
severe there's a reduced chance of
hospitalization that's now clear
it's a mixture of the virus itself
perhaps being less severe and the
immunity that's in the population but
the chance is down by somewhere between
50 and 70 percent in terms of getting
into hospitalization
so
those two things
together mean we've got a chance of more
people going into hospital because of
the degree of infection and some
lesser chance because of the mildness
what we don't know and these are two
things that we don't know that are key
we know exactly when the peak is going
to occur or how big the peaks going to
be that's one thing that will determine
how much
disease comes on in terms of
hospitalization and the second really
important thing
is that this has largely been an
infection amongst younger people up
until now and it's moving up the age
range now and as it moves up the age
range you would expect to see more
hospitalizations
and we don't know for sure how that's
going to manifest and what degree of
disease so
i think with the degree of infection
we've got we're going to see more
hospitalizations for sure
15 000 per day at the moment that i
expect to increase and that of course
will be associated with increased
pressure and ultimately uh of course
with some fatalities as well
and i think what we now need to look for
is when this peaks and starts to come
down
and let's add to that i mean i think
that from a health service point of view
uh i kind of divided into uh some some
different sort of groups
i don't think we think that the icu
pressure is going to be what it was in
previous like it was in previous waves
but there is very substantial pressure
on the emergency service part ambulances
and e's and and my colleagues in the nhs
who in the emergency side are having an
extremely difficult time because they've
got a simultaneous
wave of people coming in with covid on
top of the usual winter pressures
and you've got a wave of people who are
off sick because they have got coveted
or indeed for other reasons but kobit is
very substantially contributing to that
as patrick said we would expect the peak
in younger people to come before the
peak in older people so it may well be
that the workforce problems start to
decrease
before we start to see any decrease in
uh the number of people coming to
hospital in fact they could still work
very well still they're going up for
some time so i think
i would just associate those two and of
course workforce problems also apply to
things like people's transport uh all
the critical services and and so on so i
think they will come to they will end up
in two slightly different places because
of this age effect
in terms of threshold
for the nhs it's less that there is a
single threshold and more that little by
little
routine and then urgent but not
emergency and then so on things are
rolled back
so it's a little by little the nhs has
to retreat to the most urgent things
over time and obviously we hope that
they don't they
that we can still keep urgent but
non-emergency services running
everywhere but in every winter there's
pressures in every winter there are
times when hospitals have some
difficulties what covert of course will
do is make that considerably more
difficult so it'll be a patchy in
different areas of the country it'll be
patchy at different points along the
epidemic
and it won't reach a threshold but there
will certainly be some hospitals some
areas of the country which will come
under very substantial pressure over the
next couple of weeks and again just to
build on something that we said at the
outset when you could see how
transmissible omicron was there were
three things really that caused the big
worry hospitalizations as a key thing to
keep an eye on
staff absences as a second and things
like the testing infrastructure become
incredibly stretched as you get to these
very
high numbers and therefore become
difficult to operationalise
thanks very much hugh emily morgan of
itv
thank you prime minister you say that we
have a chance to ride this wave out
without having extra restrictions but
isn't the cost of that patient care are
you absolutely confident that all
patients will be cared for safely in the
coming weeks
thanks emily well
of course i want to thank the the nhs
for what they're doing they're doing an
amazing job and yes and i've as i've
said before i know that they are now as
chris and patrick have also said that
the nhs is now under uh a lot of
pressure uh but i'm also confident that
we can uh get through it and what we're
doing is supporting the nhs in uh any
way uh that we can uh and and we will
continue to do that but
what we what we need to do
is to remember a few things first of all
lockdowns further restrictions are not
cost free they're not cost free for uh
for lies for livelihoods for for life
chances uh closing schools these are
very very difficult uh things to to to
do and have and have long-term
consequences and as as everybody can see
although omicron does cause lots of
hospitalizations
it does result in at the moment uh
pretty clearly resulting in fewer people
in icu uh and and thankfully at the
moment uh certainly less mortality uh
than we've seen from other variants so
that's why uh we think the balanced
approach that we're taking is the is the
right one
and uh to keep going with plan b plus uh
this acceleration of the of the booster
campaign and and that's the the balance
that we're that we're striking
thanks uh emily ben kentish lbc
thank you prime minister two questions
to you if i may firstly your win to plan
for tackling covid says the government
is committed to doing whatever it takes
to prevent the nhs from being
overwhelmed but as beds fill up and one
in ten staff are off sick operations are
cancelled and more and more trusts
declare critical incidents isn't the nhs
already overwhelmed and you're not doing
very much at all to stop it and secondly
if i could on the issue of staff
absences that you've touched on at lbc
we've been hearing about lots of nhs
workers who say that even now they
haven't been given the ffp3 grade
medical masks to protect them from covid
others say they can't access lateral
flow tests to prevent them having to
isolate what would your response to them
be and if i could just tell professor
whitty uh sir chris very quickly how
frustrated are you as a medic as sir
chris about the number of that beds that
are being taken up by people who have
rejected the offer of a vaccine thank
you
thanks very much ben well look so on
your point about uh ffp 303 uh masks and
uh and and lateral flow tests i'll i
will take that up but you know we're
doing everything we can to make sure
that the uh the nhs is is supplied with
all the ppe uh that uh that they need
and uh generally speaking there's been a
heroic effort to uh to get people what
their what they are going to perhaps ask
chris to to comment on that in a minute
but on your on your basic point uh ben
about you know is the nhs overwhelmed
well look i mean the numbers are high
the numbers of people going into
hospital right now are high that's
that's clear and there are there are uh
15 000 uh currently in a covered
patients uh in the nhs in england those
as you'll have heard from chris and not
all of those uh are there
wholly and entirely because
of kovid some of them uh perhaps 25 30
of contracted uh nosocomial uh
infections you've got to think about uh
that factor you've also got to recognize
that this is a a milder
variant in the sense that it keeps
people in hospital uh perhaps for a
shorter period that's not in any way to
minimize the the pressure on the nhs now
uh it's not where it was
clearly it's not where it was in the
january uh peak
uh yet
uh
the best way that i think we can
prevent that is is to continue with the
strategy that we've we've set out and
that is everybody uh being sensible
following the the guidance uh
implementing
plan b
but also getting boosted into your point
then about
people who haven't been uh
vaccinated i mean how absolutely crazy
it is
absolutely crazy that there are two
million slots this week
for people to get vaccinated and yet uh
the the the majority of people uh in icu
uh for covid uh are not vaccinated with
61
and and the overwhelming majority of uh
of those uh in icu have not been uh
boosted i mean really uh it this is a
it's it's sad but it's also a huge
opportunity for us uh to try to to
correct it and i just say to people you
know
the boosters the vaccines really are the
way forward
uh you the prime minister asked me to
comment quickly on ffp3 i mean i think
there are two separate questions really
there's a question about what a
technical question for which there is a
debate about what are the situations
where it's useful and which are the
situations where it isn't nobody wishes
to wear an ffp3 if they don't need it
they're not much fun to work in
but on the other hand they must have
them when they are in the right place
and that's a technical discussion
and then with several different views on
it and then there's a second separate
question of if people do need it is it
available and that and in that situation
we are far better place than we were
last year but of course if anyone hears
of shortages people need to escalate
that because it is critical that people
do have the kit that's needed when uh
when they get to the point where they
need it
on the one you asked me about uh did i
would i get frustrated with the word you
think i i would say i i my experience of
having talked to people in that
situation is i'm rather saddened because
not the great majority of them they're
not anti-vaxxers in the ordinary sense
with sort of really weird ideas
but
essentially there are three questions
people want to know and answer to they
want to know is this disease important
enough to be vaccinated against and
i can say very clearly the fact they're
in hospital means pretty clearly this is
a serious disease this is a serious
serious disease the second question is
don't the vaccines work well we're very
confident the vaccines work as i say 88
protection is our current estimate may
change a bit in terms of reducing the
chance of you going to hospital even
more almost certainly going into
intensive care as the prime minister
said and the third thing and this is
where the misinformation there is around
on the internet
a lot of it deliberately placed
is a problem
is they worry about side effects and
that's understandable and it is the job
of health professionals not to get
frustrated by that but simply to say
look let's go to all of your questions
properly and systematically and say you
know which ones are fair and which ones
and as in many cases are really
completely untrue but have been put into
the public domain often deliberately to
scare people so insofar as i i'm
frustrated it's simply people
deliberately trying to scare fellow
citizens away from getting something
which is going to be potentially
life-saving for them certainly
stop them getting a hospital admission
and protect people around them the final
thing people of course then want is
convenience and that's what the booster
program has allowed is a massive
expansion of our capacity
and if people have not yet had a vaccine
at all now is a very good time to get it
there's a lot of capacity and we really
would like to use it whether it's first
second or third third doses that people
are needing
thank you uh ben rowena mason guardian
and
to the prime minister what is your
definition of the nhs becoming
overwhelmed and is this still your
guiding principle
that you would bring in restrictions if
the nhs is at that point because a lot
of people working in the health service
feel that that has been reached already
and to
the chief scientific officer and chief
medical officer do you agree with andrew
pollard of the jcbi that we can't keep
on um getting uh booster jabs every six
months that it's unsustainable for that
to just keep happening forevermore
uh
thank you very much bro you know well
look i think the nhs is under huge
pressure i won't provide a definition of
what uh being overwhelmed uh would would
constitute because i think that
different trusts in different places at
different moments uh will feel at least
temporarily overwhelmed and anybody who
you know in hospitals at the moment uh
are sending out signals as you know
rowena's saying uh that they they're
feeling uh the pressure hugely and i
understand that and i and i and i thank
them for uh the work that they're
they're doing it's absolutely fantastic
um
there are not as many uh coveted
patients in
the nhs now as there were in the january
peak not by
a long way but uh sadly uh the numbers
are likely to grow there are the various
mitigations that i've uh i've already
mentioned uh
the the relative uh mildness and itself
of the shortness of stay uh and so on
the the fact that people don't go into
icu uh nearly so much
and uh and so on as as chris and patrick
have already said but
in the end it's it's it's it's people in
the hospital
it's the pressure on a e's it's the
ambulances arriving uh that's that's
creating the
the
that huge sense of of pressure and i
totally understand that i've just got to
say to people uh that
and i as i said yesterday there will be
a difficult period for our wonderful nhs
for the next few weeks because of
omicron i just think that we have to get
through it as best as we possibly can we
will give the nhs all the support uh
that we can but in the meantime the
thing we've got to do
as responsible members of the public is
follow the uh the guidance try to stop
transmission as much as we can and uh
get boosted and you know
it's i can see the limit in the value of
of people like me uh you know endlessly
uh saying from uh our pulpits you know
come on and get vaccinated uh we do need
everybody uh to join this movement you
know and and uh there are many many uh
evangelists for this now it we need
everybody to to to to build the movement
there is a big opportunity to turn this
around nine million people still to get
a vaccine uh now's the time
in terms of the the vaccine question
um what's the good news is that as you
get um vaccinated more the immune system
broadens its response
so that it covers more variants so the
immune system tends to get broader as
you get more exposed to infection or you
get
vaccinated
and
there are different parts of the immune
system some of which have a very long
lasting memory of what you've seen
before and therefore will provide some
durability
i think andrew pollard's right it would
be
a situation that isn't tenable to say
everyone's gonna need to be
having another vaccine every three or
six months that's not the long-term view
of where this goes to there will be some
people who may require an additional
dose
but longer term i would think that as
this becomes a disease which is endemic
in other words we have it circulating it
comes back every year
it will be something like an annual
vaccine like flu or something of that
order which this moves to exactly which
vaccine that is we don't know yet that's
going to be something that people will
work on over the next months and and in
years to come as well as we think about
long-term vaccine strategies so i don't
see this as being something that you end
up having a vaccine from as frequently
as we do now we need that because it's
the very early stages of this disease
and we needed to get boosted for this
variant at this moment so i think
there'll be a change over time and this
will settle into a much more routine
type of vaccine program as we have for
other
infectious diseases
thank you uh rowena harry cole son
the
son thank you uh prime minister you said
that it will become increasingly normal
for three jabs uh to be required on
vaccine certification when are you
planning on making that the rule in in
britain and wouldn't it be totally
unfair given that millions of people
who've suffered from omicron over this
christmas period have to wait for 28
days to get their jab so can you rule
that out until february
and um prime minister if i make can i
draw your attention to an article you
wrote for the sun on the 31st of may
2016 where you said that if we leave the
eu energy bills will be lower for
everyone eu rules mean we can we cannot
take that off those bills and the least
wealthy are particularly hard you went
on to directly promise when we vote
leave we will be able to scrap this
unfair and damaging tax yet as prime
minister you're refusing calls to cut
vat or scrap v80 on energy bills what's
changed or were you misleading voters
uh not at all but on on the uh on your
point about uh certification and um and
the booster uh look i mean i i i
understand what you're what you're
saying harry and uh we certainly don't
want to do anything that's unfair to to
anybody but uh clearly that there will
be countries that are going to start uh
saying
for travel purposes for instance uh that
uh getting a booster is their uh their
condition for allowing uh brits to to
arrive there so it will be very much to
people's advantage let me put it that
way it would be very much to people's
advantage uh to to get uh your booster
and
when we propose to change the definition
of a vaccine certification i will be
sure to give people plenty of uh of time
and plenty of uh of opportunity and i
take your point about the unfairness of
for people who've had omicron over
over christmas that is a very a very
reasonable point but on your point about
um
v-a-t on on energy bills i mean i think
it is slightly paradoxical uh that this
is now being campaigned for uh by people
who actually wanted to remain in the eu
uh and and still do uh when uh it would
be impossible to deliver uh within the
eu uh we will continue to listen uh to
businesses and consumers about how to
abate uh the costs of uh of energy harry
and uh in the meantime in the meantime
there is there are all sorts of things
uh that we can do to help people and and
i appreciate the the the difficulties
that people are uh are
are facing because of the uh the
increase in gas prices uh but you know
we're we're we've got the uh the warm
home discount 140 pound a rebate on
energy bills uh winter fuel payments uh
that cover 11.4 million pensioners and
uh the cold weather payments and and so
on as well as a 500 million pound uh uh
contribution through a local government
to help uh those uh who need it most
harry i'm not ruling out uh further
measures and you are quite right to draw
tension as i did in that piece uh to the
potential uh that is contained in uh the
uh freedom to uh to regulate our own uh
our nvat whether the argument as you
know is that uh it's a bit of a blunt
instrument and uh the difficulty is that
uh you end up uh
also cutting fuel bills for a lot of
people who perhaps don't need the
support in quite the direct way uh that
we need to give it we need to help uh
people who are in uh fuel poverty the
most but as i say uh we will listen to
uh to consumers and uh and to businesses
as as we go forward and we are certainly
very and rishi
is very very mindful of the of the
increase in energy prices and the effect
of the increase in energy prices on
people up and down this country and we
are going to do what we can uh to help
chris anything you want to say about
energy prices
okay
uh
good uh who is next who's we got one
more
to go it's nick cecil was the standard
thank you
first the prime minister and to sir
chris
given the clovis situation in london and
the fact that so many central london
businesses have been so hard hit by the
plan b measures and omicron concerns
what is your message to people about
returning to youth pubs restaurants and
clubs in central london
to sir patrick do you think the omicron
wave has now peaked in london
and if so given the evidence from south
africa how quickly could cases fall
and finally prime minister
as a former mayor of london will you
push for a long-term sustainable funding
deal for transport for london to help
the city to recover
um
chris who's who's doing like who's doing
curved in london chris we both know in
different ways did you mind careful yeah
you go you're good yeah
um in terms of a message i'm gonna i'm
gonna answer that rather indirectly
uh and that is that the reason that um
so until we've actually had the peak
in the most vulnerable
that is the people who are most likely
to go to hospital
any measures that are taken that help
pull the peak down slow it down
are beneficial in terms of reducing the
height of the wave and that is having an
effect on businesses on homes and above
all on the nhs and individuals people's
health
so people have been incredibly
uh responsive and i think we should all
be incredibly grateful for the way
people responded to the fact that there
is a need unfortunately no one would
want it but there is a need for people
to be very careful still as the prime
minister said to work from home as prime
minister said to use mass but also to uh
to prioritize as we've talked about
several times uh before uh that you know
the response to that is one of the
reasons why the rates have not gone up
even faster and even further
obviously hopefully there will come a
point uh in the not too distant future
when the rates are coming down and
that's the point of which i think these
kind of things are much easier to
address but while before we've reached
the peak in the most vulnerable people
uh i think we need to keep the messaging
really really steady on this
should i build on that for the second
question
so
in terms of has it reached a peak in
london
the answer is there is no evidence it's
clearly reached a peak and whilst it may
be the case that in the younger age
groups this is flattening off or
possibly even beginning to come down
not least because they had such a big
wave of infection
that is not true in the older age groups
it's still going up in the older age
groups so i think it would be very wrong
and chris has alluded to this
to suggest that there's a peak which
means it's all over in london
it may well be flattening in some of the
younger age groups but it's in the older
age groups where we have the biggest
risk of this turning into
hospitalization and severe complications
and that is definitely not the case yet
so we need to keep watching we don't
know when the peak is going to occur or
how big it's going to be
but we need to see it happen in all the
age groups not just call it when one age
group looks as though it's turning
and then
just to build on the other point about
um plan b
it wasn't plan b alone that was
important to bring it down it was the
behavior that everyone took up really
well in the run-up to christmas and over
the holiday period to change their
behaviors to try and reduce social
contacts
as initially suggested by jenny harris
and chris before christmas that's a
really important part of this and until
we've got to
the older age groups coming down it's
important that we retain that caution
yeah and nick on your on your point
about uh transport for for london uh
never forget that it was left with a a
very considerable uh sum of money by the
the outgoing uh the previous uh mayor
who who you know left the coppers full
uh
and uh not not least to the the
crossroads and everything else however
uh we are where we are and it is vital
that our great capital cities got to be
able to uh to move around uh of course
ridership has been down uh because of
the pandemic but i know you and i
and and the current mayor and nick
devoutly hope that that ridership uh
will come back and one day it will come
back without masks on uh we hope and uh
our city will be uh our capital city
will be buzzing uh again uh and so it's
vital that london uh is properly uh
provided for but what it also requires
is a mayor who's going to institute a
sensible uh and pragmatic affairs policy
uh and not the uh the retrograde one
that we saw uh the uh the early stage of
the the current mayor's uh term so
that's what we're uh that's what we're
looking to uh to achieve okay uh on on
that the unesc perspective want to say
anything about uh affairs in uh on
london transport i think uh we will
conclude that thank you everybody thank
you
so there we are the first coved news
conference of 2022
and uh almost certainly not the last
boris johnson saying that the battle
with kovid is not over but he said we
know omicron is milder we know we have a
measure of protection and with plan b we
can find a way to live with the virus
and ride out the omicron wave without
shutting down
our country
once again he also talked about the
importance of people getting jabbed he
said it is absolutely crazy that two
million slots are available
this
week patrick valance said it's mainly an
infection of the young but moving now
into older age groups our political
elder beth rigby is uh still with us so
beth the nhs is on a war footing he says
but on measures and restrictions it's
well basically as we are
yes mark that really was a packed press
conference wasn't it so much information
and updates about omicron how it's
transmitting the severity of the disease
and what it all means for us in our
daily lives and i think the big takeaway
from that clearly was the prime minister
announcing as we expected that for now
he is sticking with plan b there was a
big focus we can get into that
on booster programme
and vaccination a big emphasis on that
and testing as well but when it came uh
to the decisions he's taken about policy
he said that the combination of people
adhering to plan b and implementing
those measures as well as omicron being
milder than was feared perhaps in
december when the scientists just didn't
have enough data meant that to quote the
prime minister we have a chance to ride
out this wave of omicron without
shutting down our country once again but
the weeks ahead are going to be
challenging and he did say later it
really does depend on how things play
out uh in the coming weeks so sticking
to plan b he said he'll recommend that
to his
cabinet uh tomorrow and a big focus
there on vaccines and testing
okay beth thank you very much indeed uh
well joining us